Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so DC day is not
over.
They dropped some new Justice league and they
were talking about a Superman TV show eventually
coming to the CW, there is a new round of
the flash ring giveaway going on right now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I'll be
announcing winners at the end of the video
so be sure to click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything get a lot of questions
about the giveaways the winners always announced
at the end of videos.
So what's going on today is like a DC day.
They dropped that promo announce that all
of the DC TV shows were coming back basically
enough like the black flash they announced
so LaVar then wall that was all going on this
Justice league stuff dropped and you can kind
of see this is the bat jet is basically like
a big jumbo jet the Bruce Wayne and Wayne
Tech have repurpose is sort of like a mobile
fortress that they fly around and so this
is them climbing out the back getting ready
to kick some ass the biggest thing that everyone
is noting here, in addition to like the way
they show off their costumes which look like
way more detailed we see in the past is that
there's no Superman, so presumably this is
happening relatively early in the film, but
after Aquaman has joined the team because
during the trail that they showed off a comic
con like the test footage they were still
trying to get a better fight with more more
more less and Batman's like you he said no.
So something can have to happen in the movie
with dark side's minions change Aquaman's
mind.
Usually it's like the threat on Atlanta's
like of something threatens the season the
people he cares about those of the things
that are really at stake for him because is
not friends with any of these people.
Yet eventually will become comrades and he
give their life for them, but in just a slave
they're just not there yet.
Like they haven't got to that point, so the
flash is like the only one in addition to
wonder woman who is like totally down to help
out.
It really just based on what they've shown
us the flash is the only one who is super
eager wonder woman wants to help out, but
she is like jumping up and down to hang out
with Batman but just look at some of these
costume.
So his gun like the behind-the-scenes look
so you see the little bit of it without CG.
This looks very close to what is actually
look like in the film that this is like a
picture that was copied a couple different
times so does look quite as colorful as it
will in the movie but you do see Batman's
new suit.
They were to show that off a little bit he
has the goggles but is basically like a slightly
more armored version of his cloth suit a lot
more mobile than the tank suit that he wore
when he was fighting Superman is kind of that
dark night joke where Lucius Fox is like you
want to be able to turn your head while you're
wearing the bat suit.
This is a suit built for fighting.
Demons hard-core enough that it will defend
them against a couple blows lightweight enough
that he can move around in tight confined
spaces.
I really did like the way the Batman moved
around during Batman view Superman.
They did take some liberties like he seems
superstrong but it's a comic book movies so
I think most people understood that when they
introduced him that underground there.
He really does kind of move around like a
bat just like clinging to the ceilings.
It was great using the wonder woman trailer.
So you know how she moves you see her there
with the God killer sword.
That's the sort of Athena is capable of piercing
doomsday is well Superman skin so she as well
as Aquaman are actually going to be very important
for fighting Steppenwolf because he'll probably
be just as tough as doomsday obviously like
a slightly different type of fight than them
fighting doomsday because the be physically
smaller but Aquaman very important to that,
because his trident is also capable of piercing
doomsday as well Superman skin, so anytime
you have someone with a weapon or, with like
a physical ability like a metahuman ability
like the flash that's capable of harming someone
that's as strong as a dark side or his minions
are Superman.
They become the most important person in that
fight.
So, I know a lot of questions like how powerful
is this version of the flash.
The way they're presenting him say like compared
to the TV show version of the flash grant
Gustin's flash is that you have to imagine
TV flash moving at superspeed at all times
and then briefly slowing down just so that
he can interact with other people, but for
the most part he experiences the world in
that superfast state which is why he has all
these monitors on even the Rick and Morty
monitor over there.
You can see in the background he's moving
so fast that it seems like he can take that
all in at the same time.
Even though you know when he's moving at superspeed
he still reading it just like a normal person
would read it or watching that episode of
TV, so if you didn't see the videos I did
during the summer there was a big set visit
a bunch of people got to watch them film a
scene the flash really helps anchor the tone
of the film makes it more humorous just more
fun like oh my God this is so amazing I can't
believe we'll get to team up, the biggest
question is cyborg obviously they done a lot
more CG work on this version of the costume
then in the test footage we saw, can't think
you that was really just preliminary stuff
this is actually much closer to what it look
like during the film, which is just nuts and
Superman's costume.
I don't think is going to change too much
it'll seem more colorful like the blues in
the Reds will stand out war but that's really
I think just in the way that they edit the
film just the way they colored time it they
wanted to see much more like brightest day
than blackest night like Batman view Superman
was meant to be this really dark serious tone
Justice league is still dark but it's a lot
more hopeful than Batman view Superman.
I like all these but ranking them from favorite
to least favorite I'll say Aquaman is my favorite
right now, his armor look so bad ass in the
trident.
I can't wait to see them in action with full
CG than the bat suit then wonder woman's costume
than the flash and cyborg, just because I
haven't really seen with the cyborgs costume
does its full CG meaning that it's going to
be moving around a lot.
Lots of moving parts, but until we get the
first trailer we just won't know how that's
gonna work, and I know everybody wants to
know when that, first trailer is gonna drop
they were originally gonna drop it sometime
in December but now, it sounds like all the
election stuff that's happening scared them
off in their getaway to the spring.
So we or anything else about it I will totally
included in future Justice league videos.
So let me know whose costume is your favorite
from the Justice league, so far, but what
about the Superman TV show that everyone was
going crazy about it was like a little bit
of a tease at the TCAs.
So like I said in the drop this flash season
for arrow season six DC TV promo and they
talked a little bit about the Superman property
like hey you know Superman was awesome this
year.
On Supergirl, are you going to make a Superman
TV show Greg Berlanti said that there really
hopeful in the future that they can do that
but they're not actively developing one right
now.
So Tyler Hoechlin is as close were gonna get
to a Superman TV show in the near term, but
eventually we will see that Smallville reboot.
Even though I don't think that it will literally
be a Smallville reboot it be like some different
type of Superman show that we haven't seen
before but in the way that the Berlanti verse
brings back classic actors for the new TV
shows I do think there's a solid chance that
when we do get to that Superman TV show bring
back Tom Welling in some rural just depending
on how far in the future that is like he might
not quite be old enough to play jaw rel.
But they could do a Jay Garrick Jon Wesley
Shipp type thing where he plays a version
of Superman from a different earth because
we do have the multi-verse.
So next couple years know Superman TV show
just Superman on the Supergirl TV show.
Let me know in the comments though, when they
do get to it.
What do you want them to do for Superman.
Do you want to be a metropolis do you want
to be in Smallville you want him to be part
of the Justice league.
I feel like we want Justice league if all
the shows are still on TV we want TV Justice
league congratulations to the new flash ring
giveaway winner Alex gets toasty please private
message me on the back and my channel so I
can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video so.
Just remind everyone the next time I post
a DC video while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to learn all about
the flash season for the shows that are coming
back and you can click here for the trailer
for the next episode of the flash thank you
so much watching I'll see you guys next video!